c'était finalement une évidence qu'il
fallait raconter l'histoire de belles de
sa famille et de la façon dont cette
fille va se dévouer va se sacrifier pour
que son père vivent en allant se met
entre les griffes de cette bête dont
elle va tomber mais c'est vrai que la
façon dont sandra s'empare du personnage
et le nourrit en fait de contradictions
cette façon dont tout cela est mis en
forme fait que des acteurs en plongée
tout de suite
fort dans le personnage de la bête ces
on n'avait pas une fille qui subit elle
cherche elle transgresse les règles de
la bête et puis à lui tient tête enfin
tout ce qu'on devrait pouvoir faire et
que parfois on ne sait pas faire pour ça
que c'est tellement libérateur décrire
un personnage comme la belle parce que
c'est de se dire voilà un moment quand
son intégrité physique était menacée
elle sel sel s'est renversé la situation
et s'est renversé la vapeur
peut-être que jamais j'avais donné un
rôle pareil une actrice femme léa s'est
emparé de son personnage il est clair
qu'il ya une rencontre entre les a et le
genre du film de léa actrice de cinéma
d'auteur en france a toujours rêvé de
faire un film féerique et il sait et la
rencontre s'est produit